Marion Williamson is now being accused
she's now being accused of abusive
Behavior to staff or something like that
which makes them maybe I'll support her
it's turning into a definite and I don't
know what
um people don't understand about these
Crystal [__] I'm gonna call them
have you ever met these Crystal [__]
the crystal [__] will fly off the
handle like no one else people that are
Zen and go it's all just and Marianne
Williams has got that Twang and she goes
the Health Care system in America and it
is not there is a difference between
health insurance and health care and
Healthcare you know and and when she is
you know she has that nice soft voice
and she's just trying to tell you about
life because life is about energy and
energy is is all around us at all times
and it's a choice it's making a choice
and I'm a narcissist I think only in
myself every minute of the day but I
actually talk about others but when I'm
talking about other people I'm thinking
only in myself and my energy and how I'm
feeling and what I need to do and other
people are actually just ideas to me
that's me I'm Marianne Williamson and
and these and by the way that doesn't
mean she can't do some good [__] if she
gets in there because a lot of people do
good stuff by accident most of them but
Marianne Williamson's a crystal [__]
and these Crystal [__] fly off the
[__] handle you know people say it
would be foaming spitting uncontrollable
rage said a former staffer who like most
people that spoke with Politico was
granted Adam and anonymity because of
their concerns about being sued for
breaking non-disclosure agreements it
was traumatic and the experience in the
end was terrifying because here's what
makes Marion Williamson terrifying the
rage is unexpected when you work from
you know if you work for Chris Christie
a big fat guy you know he's gonna blow
up he's going to blow up blood sugar is
low can I pay a [__] but when you work
for Marion Williams it all starts like
this it starts like this we can do real
good things together we can do real good
thing now did you get did you get me my
coffee
you did okay it's a little cold now
it's a little this cough is a little
cold it no it's a little cold the car
that's all no it's not a big deal
you know the real problem in this
country is you know people are living in
food deserts and they don't have access
to you know high quality vegan meals you
know what I got to be honest this coffee
is kind of bothering me a little more
than I thought it would be but it it's
it's fine I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
make are you Mexican by any chance I
love that I spent time in Santa Fe uh
there was a writer's Retreat I was a
writer I am a writer I am a writer I
wrote all of my I don't do ghost writers
the people will tell you I actually
wrote all of my books
um and I was in Santa Fe we did a
writer's Retreat and uh the Mexicans
were actually because so much of what we
eat here that's Mexican food is very
unhealthy but that's not what they eat
Mexico they eat a lot of braises and
meats and stews and there's actually a
lot of vegetables and uh I I learned
that it's like I'm drinking iced coffee
actually it's really it feels like I'm
I'm drinking ice here which is not what
I'm trying to do I'm trying to warm my
soul but anyway in Santa Fe at the
writer's Retreat I'm a writer I I was
sitting there
and these lovely abuelas is that what
you call them these abuelas these
Mexican grandmothers oh man they might
have been uh 80 90 150 years old I don't
know but these Abuelos would come in
every day with these blankets now I
swear they'd knit these blankets
overnight and they'd knit them with the
spirit of their people it was beautiful
and they would come in and you know
every now and then they would swaddle me
like a child and put me to sleep and the
the thing about when the cough is cold
the thing about it is it hurts my throat
and my throat gets cold that's the thing
that's the only problem that's the only
problem honey so what I'm saying is and
do you have an abuela oh she's she's
passed on into the other realm well I
mean
peace to her but these are boilers would
they would they would they would they
would swaddle me
and they would just they would tell me
the tales of the that they would tell
the Mexican children and I just and from
that it was just such a beautiful moment
of transference of energy from one
abuela to a young writer in Santa Fe New
Mexico did I did I ask for a lemon bar I
think I I did am I losing my mind am I
losing my mind or did I ask for a lemon
bar okay because we're trying to change
the world here we're trying to change
the [__] world okay and I'm telling
you right now for the love of God if you
[__] with me here and I'm just trying to
put it I'm a little late on the line I'm
just gonna lay it online my goal is to
help other people but if you [__] with
me here I swear to God I swear to God
I'll come back and I'll kill you from
every life I'll kill you from every
[__] lifetime that I've ever lived
I'm drinking icy [__] coffee I'm the
only person in America that went to the
writer's retreat in Santa Fe and was
swallowed by old Mexican abuelas so that
I could come here and communicate the
truth from their ancient people and I'm
telling you right now I shouldn't be
drinking cold coffee without a [__]
lemon bar I'm just saying honey I'm not
trying to fly off the handle I'm not
trying to fly are you gay my first
husband was gay and that was fine I knew
that when I married him it didn't matter
because I believe in energy and energy
is the purest form of love and it didn't
matter to me that he had sex with man
that didn't really bother me what
bothered me was the lying isn't it
always lying that bothers you that's
what bothered me I would tell him I
would say listen to me Christopher kind
of a gay name Christopher I'd say
Christopher I know everything you're
doing and with everybody and that's fine
with me I just don't need you lying
about it I don't need you lying about it
and it's just like you know it's one of
those things in life and you know we're
great friends to this day I mean we we
of course have the restraining order he
has one on me so I cannot see him in the
physical person but we are always
communicating through our dreams and um
I'm just telling you this I'm just
telling you right this right now if
there's ever cold coffee on this [__]
desk again I'm gonna [__] murder you
you understand I'm going to kill you and
then I will kill you as many times as I
can I will chase you through these lives
because we get many lifetimes but here's
the thing in every lifetime I've been a
self-important [__] and I will always be
a self-important white woman and a con
always you understand that [__] dummy
you understand that you dumb [__] you're
poor as [__] that's why you can't eat
good food like I do you poor fat [__]
America is a bunch of poor fat [__]
because they can't eat stars like I do I
eat the [__] Milky Way and the Galaxy
not that [__] bar I eat raw energy
[__]
I eat agave syrup and I put it in my
that's what I do I own a farm of agave
cactuses and I rub my [__] with them the
spiky ones that's what I do and then I
offer the blood as a sacrifice to Odin
if you ever [__] with my coffee again
I'll rip your [__] throat out I'll
rip your [__] throat out you dirty
[__] do you understand me you dirty
dirty dirty wet back [__] get my [__]
coffee right or I'll kill you
but that's what happens to people uh
like Marion Williamson because again
they are in a different vibrational
plane they don't need
um a lot of the things that we need
um they are fed um by energy and and uh
but she's our favorite I hope she sticks
with this I hope she doesn't leave I
want to see her flip out more because
you got to remember when you're a
crystal [__]
everything's about you
everything's about you right so whenever
that Apple card is upset even the
slightest bit
a real nightmare